crispy honey bun says I don't think we
will ever fully know if Matt is an alien
believer or if this is all just a
masterfully comedic performance and
these comments every single time I talk
about this issue
how marginalized you think this makes me
how alone in the world we may not be
alone in the universe but how alone does
it make me feel that even when I try to
express myself speaking from the
greatest depths of my heart as a member
of the ABC alien believe in community
that when I do that all I get is
laughter when people say oh what a great
joke man I'm not joking about this
I don't joke in general I don't believe
in it and I certainly would not joke
about this